i often get asked the question ispca is
still relevant
and i think that is a ridiculous
question that's an asinine question
the question is
how could you take
so little and do so much how could you
take so little and produce some of the
greatest graduates our country is ever
known
we were not allowed to attend the
majority institutions we had to come to
our own institutions historical black
colleges universities but to be
successful as university requires
funding and this is one thing with help
from tsu
[Music]
you cannot talk about fairness and
equality if you do not provide the equal
amount of funding that you're required
by federal law it speaks louder than any
words about equality and justice
this has been happening for decades and
decades and decades it is an example of
institutional racism
the states were supposed to give these
schools money
and quite frankly they didn't
how many more students
could these institutions graduated if
they had received their proper funding
how many more
research opportunities would be made at
tennessee state how many more lives
would have been changed if tennessee
state did not have this huge average
amount owed to them by the state
tennessee
we don't want to continue to promise
to do what was in law
and continue to just say
no
that was done too many times to
tennessee state
[Music]
my name is janet lauren and i write
about finances of higher ed here at
bloomberg i decided to look into about
20 public schools in the south when i
heard about how they have not been
funded for decades and decades from
their states
an important job at bloomberg is
following the money
and it was clear in this case there
wasn't as much money to follow
hbcus are very important historically
they launched the careers of luminaries
such as martin luther king jr thurgood
marshall tony morrison vice president
kamala harris and oprah winfrey because
i didn't go to stanford
i went to tennessee state university we
have a lot of first generation college
students they come to tennessee state
university they go to other hbcus
because they want to break their cycle
of poverty
education is a first step to breaking
that cycle to live in a new economic
base that's what we're seeking and
that's where hbcus have become so
important
during the civil war
in 1862
the united states under the leadership
of president abraham lincoln created the
land grant system of universities and
that essentially created a type of
university that was public previously
people in the united states only went to
college if they were extremely rich
think of harvard yale and princeton or
they were going to become a minister
the government decided to help create
public universities
where students could learn about
agriculture military farming
[Music]
after the civil war during
reconstruction
states in the south did not want to
educate former slaves and black students
so the united states government came up
with a second moral act in 1890 and they
said if there is going to be
discrimination in admissions that there
should be a second land-grant university
so this gave students the opportunity to
be educated at another place if the
university of georgia or the university
of florida or the university of
tennessee didn't want to educate black
students
there's the federal funds that had to be
matched by the state then there's a
state funding that's provided to
land-grant institutions
and in both those areas we'll fallen
short tsu got to show you another stick
i get calls regularly from other
hbcus that are land grant
and the same matching funds are owed to
them
there are new developments in the death
of george floyd the unarmed black man in
minneapolis who died in police custody
post the death of george floyd these
issues are being discussed in the
tennessee state legislature several
legislative committee
were held over several months to discuss
what tennessee state university didn't
get and i think that is a turning point
and that hasn't happened in other
southern states before some legislators
say they didn't know about it
[Music]
good afternoon
i would like to call the joint land
grant institution funding study
committee to order
harold love is a state legislator in
tennessee
he went to tennessee state his parents
met at tennessee state his grandmother
went to tennessee state she became a
teacher his wife went to tennessee state
last year we were
the legislature charged with discovering
if there were funding inequities
for the two land grants we have here in
tennessee and i along with senator
richard briggs were charged as the
chairs of this committee so our task is
to investigate to see if tennessee state
university may have been underfunded by
the state of tennessee this is going to
be a deep dive
into
land grants and the benefits how we're
funded and i really hope that out of
this we come up with some idea of going
forward
how
we can be a model
for other states
we looked into the situation and
discovered that indeed tennessee state
was being underfunded at that moment by
at least one million dollars per year
and that's a state requirement that is
supposed to match federal funds for the
land grant funding what we found was the
primarily white institutions always
received their funding
and the predominantly black hbcu
institutions did not receive their
funding
when you have funding mechanisms in
place that creates a difference in
between them that is discrimination
we began with a study of about 2000 to
2016 those years discovered that there
was 37 million dollars that was not
funded to tsu that time but this still
was not the major piece i knew that
there was more there than just this 37
million dollars but we did not have the
data
[Music]
i needed to first go and look in the
budget books
to find out if the state had put
anything in the budget books for
tennessee state
so i go to the state archives library
that we have in the building
and i start with 1957
open the book to see
where tennessee state's
deficiency is i want to see how much
they have not funded tennessee state
so
i noticed that there's no entry like
literally tennessee state is not listed
for their land grant funding
so i said okay this is one year when
there was nothing in the budget
so i said well let me look in the next
year and see if there's maybe this was
just one year when it wasn't there
i look in the next year
there's no money there i skip ahead and
say well maybe that was just that decade
but come back to 1950s but i go to the
1960s there's no money there so i
decided to spend the whole day there
looking through all the budget books
from the 1957 period to 2007 and in each
instance what i discovered was
there was not an entry in the budget
books for tennessee state
and unfortunately my worst fears were
confirmed by the house budget office
they too
did their research and discovered that
tennessee state was not allocated their
funding in those decades that's not even
the word land grant in the budget book
[Music]
my father served in legislature from
1968 to 1994
and upon winning my election i went to
my parents house and was going through
my father's office
just trying to find some things that i
may be able to take into my office
discovered this book called the special
financial needs of negro universities
you know at that time didn't look into
and read because i'm gathering documents
i'm trying to figure out how i can make
the point a bit more salient for my
colleagues downtown it's not getting
much traction
and then i get this sense of this voice
saying to me read the report
so i read the report
in this report it details how tennessee
state had been underfunded and how they
had appointed a legislative committee in
1970
to investigate this
but nothing was done
not one recommendation was followed that
the committee made
but something's wrong if harold left
senior was making these recommendations
in 2021 harold love juniors having to
make those same ones something's wrong
it disturbs me
that 50 years later
i'm making the same argument
that document became i think the
catalyst for getting
tennessee state their state match
funding that year but also became the
catalyst for us having documentation for
this new committee that we were starting
the unfortunate reality is
the state did not value
tennessee state as much as the
university of tennessee at knoxville and
some may view that as a harsh statement
that i'm making but i'm looking at the
data
thank you for the opportunity to present
to you today so during the hearings some
budget analysts looked through the books
and came up with a couple of
calculations from 150 million to 544
million that could be owed to tennessee
state
so the question is what happens next
north nashville as we mentioned a hard
hit area by monday night's tornadoes you
walk around the campus of tennessee
state
and you see the facilities some were
destroyed by a tornado in march of 2020
and the agriculture dean tells me they
likely will not be rebuilt for at least
two years after that
so you get the sense of
what potentially could have been if a
school had more money and as we pan
across here to the more agriculture
center these are the greenhouses here at
tsu you can see all the panels on top
that would cover those just flew off the
greenhouses and a bunch of other
facilities they were completely now
bulldozed out these were beautiful
greenhouses where we were doing a lot of
outstanding research work and now you
got a bunch of rubble here
we lost
several facilities
in our research station
the nashville research station it's a
it's a big disappointment you can see if
you talk to any of our faculty
you'll get more frustration than i can
express really and then if a university
is taking two years to build something
that we lost in a tornado that doesn't
generate
much confidence either when you look at
the poultry house on tsu's campus you
see a building that was destroyed by the
tornado but one that is still left but
is in bad condition because that
building was built in 1970.
i mean if you bring a faculty member
here and say we want you to do research
here they see this equipment there's no
way they're going to agree to come here
and and be a faculty member to do
research on with equipment this old no
you're driving them away this is just an
example though we got we got uh
all of our buildings are so dated we
can't attract them the high schools have
better facilities these days yeah
so you create this environment where you
have deferred maintenance on buildings
you have lower scholarship offerings for
students you have lower salaries for
teachers and you most certainly have
lower endowment levels for your
university
it is now our responsibility as stewards
of state government
to ensure that this state institution is
properly funded
tsu has gotten more money from the state
in recent years they've been able to get
better resources and they've been able
to get more competitive grants but the
question is
what could these schools have look like
if historically they had gotten a lot
more money
the arrearage amount that the state
tennessee owes to tennessee state
represents
generations of african-americans that
could have been educated
it represents
countless opportunities for the
community to be enhanced because of
tsu's presence in
nashville when he mentions the word of
rearage and and that's looking back
we've already been over that we have to
look at what we're going to be what
we're going to do going forward not
trying to remedy completely something in
the past we can't
you know look backwards and go forward
we don't need to be trying to operate
looking in the rearview mirror i hear
some of our members saying that we can't
look back i do think that we have to
take in consideration
um some of the things that have happened
in the past in order for us to build uh
on the future to this year's hbcu
graduates and to all your loved ones
who've helped you reach this day
congratulations the biden administration
has earmarked and given money to hbcus
in a way that we really haven't ever
seen before the administration has made
hvcus a priority
and while in some cases that doesn't
make up for decades and decades in the
past
it is a new page going forward
it's not just a dollar figure because it
goes beyond that it affects the lives of
the community a grave injustice took
place but right now we want them to make
the correction because it's never too
late to do what's right
you